welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
now here's a remember here's a number i
want you to remember
61 312.
that's the number of illegal immigrants
the biden administration
has released into the country in just
the first three full months of its
control of america
february march and april compare that to
the last
three full months of presidents
president trump's term
october november and december the number
of migrants released then
was 47. yes we went from the size of
a ping pong tournament at your local
ymca
to hard rock stadium where the miami
dolphins play on sunday and it's only
four months into the administration so
catch and release is back in a very big
way
under president biden and kamala harris
and what else is the administration
doing
well they're planning to increase
capacity to accommodate
more of the migrants that they do choose
to keep detained
meanwhile the so-called borders are
kamala harris has literally
had nothing to say about the issue since
being put in charge
just about two months ago and having
never visited the border
since she's been the vice president but
her old friend and home state
governor gavin newsom isn't staying
silent in fact
he's had some ideas on how to spend his
state's unexpected budget surplus
more like giveaways to illegal
immigrants including
105 million dollars for humanitarian
relief
50 million dollars for english classes
and
14 million dollars for legal aid
all for migrants and migrants only and
they wonder why
people keep coming here with reaction
the former acting secretary of the
department of homeland security chad
wolfe
and the current attorney general of
arizona mark brnovich uh mr attorney
general i i want to start with you
uh look we we've got them streaming in
by the tens of thousands
uh you take that trajectory over a long
period of time
it's gonna be hundreds of thousands of
people a lot of them are coming to
arizona but my question is when they
catch and release somebody
what are those people in arizona or if
they migrate up to nevada or
arizona or iowa or whatever or utah
what where are they supposed to live
where are they supposed to get an income
how are they supposed to provide for
their families like what are they
supposed to do
that is legal and lawful under our laws
in the united states
jason it is absolutely heartbreaking and
despicable
what the biden administration is doing
and we were talking about these numbers
you were just talking about numbers
2 million 2 million is the number of
estimated people
across just this year across our
southern border that's like the state of
alaska wyoming and vermont combined in
one year
we know the cartels are enriching
themselves every single person that
crosses this border
we know as a result of recent discovery
in our lawsuit one of our lawsuits
against
the biden administration and its
immigration policies
is as a result of that they're not
picking up people that are being
released from prison so you have
felons you have arsonists you have
aggravated assaults sexual predators
that ice is not picking up they're not
deporting
and as you just said they're being
released into our community so this is
not an arizona problem
it's not a texas it's not a border
problem this will affect every person in
the united states
you know john f kennedy put a man on the
moon this
biden is going to end up putting a felon
in everyone's neighborhood that to me is
how much
how far the democratic party has changed
just in 40 years it's shameful
now chad when i was in congress we held
hearings because
obama biden what they did is they
released more than 60 000 people out in
the homeland
these were people that were convicted of
a crime here in the united states
and instead of deporting them they just
released them back out into
to the homelands more than sixty
thousand but we're just talking about
the first few months
and and i have seen kamala harris
absolutely
nowhere on this issue
well absolutely jason i think what the
last four months of this
administration has seen the policies
have failed the american people have
failed the law enforcement officers of
the department of homeland security and
most of all
have failed the migrants because it's
the bite administration that's
encouraging these individuals to take
this very dangerous journey
through mexico at the hands of the
cartels and the traffickers and the
smugglers
and we know that there's a lot of
dangerous things that go on during that
journey so
across the board the policies the
messaging from this administration has
absolutely failed
the american people the migrants and
others and absolutely it's absolutely
crazy that the vice president vice
president harris has not
visited the border has not talked to the
law enforcement officers
their job is to secure that border every
day to understand their challenges to
understand what they're going through
so that she can become an advocate for
them and help them do their job
and negotiate with the northern triangle
in mexico instead
she will not go to that border and i
think that is
a disservice not only to the the men and
women of dhs but really to the american
people
yeah mr attorney general i got to tell
you that democrats try to play the
compassion card oh we care more
these are real families and they are
real families but it's not compassionate
to encourage them to make this
treacherous travel northbound i mean
when i talk to border patrol agents
they're telling me that
somewhere between 60 and 100 percent of
the women that are coming north are
being raped along the way
yeah jason look i'm i'm a first
generation american
i understand why people want to come to
this country but we're a nation of laws
the reason why so many people are
fleeing
you know communist countries and third
world countries is because the rural law
means something we have a system of laws
and what the bible administration is
doing is i believe long-term wise
is undermining immigration because what
is going to end up happening is when you
have felons released into the
communities
and god forbid these dangerous crimes
occur it's going to affect us
when you have the cartels making all
this money and an increase in fentanyl
and heroin coming across our border
that is going to poison our
neighborhoods people are going to die of
overdoses
don't forget what the bite
administration done when the biden
administration is talking about sending
310 million dollars
to central american countries to prop
them up that's our tax dollars
when they talk about house paying 87
million dollars to for contracts to
house people don't have legal status
here
think about that next time you got to
write your check for your mortgage and
so this
actually is creating i think a great
division in our country not sure what
the bite administration is doing but
long-term wise i think it's going to
tear this country apart
chad i've got 10 seconds left your last
thoughts
yeah well i think what's concerning
that's going on at the border is is bad
enough but
the fact that the bite administration
has also
handcuffed ice from removing individuals
while they're here in the interior of
their country so their plan is to let
them in
and then the plan is to restrict law
enforcement's ability to remove them at
the end of the day
it's true it is absolutely disgusting
gentlemen thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else